you guys use react some of you okay so I
am going to talk a little bit about
react the vast majority of this talk
despite the fact that I'm using react
it's built within the context of create
react app the vast majority of it will
apply anywhere right because once you
get into service workers I manifested
all that stuff it doesn't matter what
framework were you're in so it sort of
work for you
alright I'm from here I am NOT from here
but actually interesting is whenever I
tell people I'm from the United States
they think of Los Angeles or New York
City I'm from neither of those places
but actually it's kind of fun so we're
in Portugal you know that but which is
kind of fun because I grew up in Maine
so it's kind of neat to stand on the
coast of Portugal just right down the
street like I can look if I look in the
right direction it's like that's where I
grew up right over there I've never seen
Maine from that side before so it's
interesting not just right now I live in
Kansas City so literally the farthest
possible point I can get from the ocean
or the two places everybody thinks of
when they think of the United States
like I'm in the middle
it's basically America's version of
Germany like think Germany is right in
the middle same thing okay that's enough
about me I'm John for those of you who
don't know I Laurel slide author I'm a
consultant I do all those things if you
want to talk about that later let me
know anybody used full site
I always forget to do this I'll remember
okay if you don't use floral site I have
trial cards like I can get you 30 days
of all access to Pluralsight if you're
interested in that afterwards let me
know I will hand them out I always
forget to do that so okay how many of
you have seen this page well you've been
here this last couple of days right so
this is the schedule for NBC Porto and
oh I haven't I haven't tried to much
while I've been here I think things have
been pretty
how many of you when trying to get to
this page have seen this page nobody the
Wi-Fi here has been great hasn't it so
that kind of defeats the purpose of my
entire talk but that's okay imagine if
you will we had bad Wi-Fi and we didn't
want to see this page we want to see
this page right so that's the number one
negative of a web app is it only works
when you're online right it seems
obvious but that's that can be pretty
detrimental especially when you're in
poor Wi-Fi area or you know your mobile
networks not good and so that's become
much more of a problem especially for an
app like this look I just want to see
what the schedule is I don't need to be
online I know all that information so
what's the alternative we build a mobile
app how many of you have downloaded the
NBC mobile application oh that's pretty
good but some of you have not why
haven't you like if you didn't download
it why not
because it's hard right you got to go to
the App Store you got to click download
you got a deal with permissions it's
it's painful and so what you'll find is
especially for things like this people
just you guys are fantastic because you
followed instructions and you went you
downloaded it but a lot of people are
not gonna do that they're not gonna go
download the mobile app so the problem
is now you you need something to fill
the gap in between these two extremes
and so this that's where progressive web
apps come in so progressive web apps try
and sit in the middle between a
full-blown mobile app and a web app that
doesn't work when when it's offline so
the key aspect of a progressive web app
is it's gonna work
it's gonna work when you're offline it's
gonna work all the time reliable a
progressive web app is defined by three
key things and I'm gonna we're gonna
talk deeply about all three of these
things but the number one most important
thing about a progressive web app is it
works
always
no matter what my Wi-Fi connection is
like them but I can get to it it works
it's fast we're going to talk a little
bit about this too because sometimes
it's not that your your Wi-Fi connection
is gone sometimes is that your Wi-Fi
connection is just slow and so you want
things to work quickly and we'll talk a
little bit about what that means - the
last thing we're going to talk about is
engaging and so engaging means maybe
something a little bit different yes
it's got to work because the reality is
how many of you when you are looking at
a website do you always look at a
website here for the vast majority of my
life I look at websites here right I'll
work here and then when I need to like
go do something just on the web I'll
switch and I'll just use my phone and
this is what much of the world does now
so we need our websites or our web apps
to work equally here as they do here so
that's part of the engaging partner and
so this is better this concepts that are
out for a long time right so responsive
web design we want things to look
differently how many if you use
bootstrap kind of solves that problem a
little bit for you the other side of
engaging is what if for a website and
you guys have probably seen this a lot
when the websites not even open what if
I can send push notifications to your
website to your browser just like I went
to a mobile app and that's the other
part of the engaging piece is I'm gonna
send push notifications to your phone
even when your browser is closed so I'll
show you how that happens - all right so
let's look at this thing I have built a
react application now there's a lot of
stuff here and I'm not gonna talk about
all the stuff but there's a lot of stuff
here basically I just did create react
app scheduled spun up a new thing
if you do react as a general rule you
well I don't care you should be using
create react up right how how many of
you use create react up like if you
don't use create react up then you're
dealing with all kinds of configuration
files and all the stuff that you just
don't want to deal with so I just did
Korea react up spun up a new thing and
this app does one thing I'll actually
just spin it up and then to do I'll spin
it up and then I'll show you what it
does
OOP okay so basically what this
application does is this the agenda it's
the NBC Porto agenda that's all it is
now this is demo so like nether to
ignore all the stuff across the top none
of that works right it's just this page
and so what happens is as I click
between Thursday and Friday I get the
two different days so let me show you
how that works real quick for context
and then we'll kind of dig into it so I
have an app jus and in my app J yes I
have some days Thursday and Friday so I
set my state and I have selected as
Thursday which is day zero then when I
click a different day it just flips and
I do a get talks and all get talks does
is there's an axial get which is like a
fetch do you how many of you use Axios
right so Axios is basically it wraps
fetch right so I just use it for all of
my HTTP calls so Axios not get I get the
next day JSON which is these two things
over here it's just my schedule and then
I display it you may think going back to
the network every time I click one of
those two things is a little silly but I
have to do that otherwise I can't demo
the whole progressive web app thing for
you so that's why I do that okay so
that's my app that's all there is to it
it's very simple it's very
simplistic sohere's inspects so check
this out
when I go to network and I reload it see
I go do a whole bunch of stuff and then
I click on Friday and you'll see down at
the bottom if you're in the back you may
not see it I'm going back for day one
day zero day one back and forth keep
going there is in chrome dev tools this
little button right here that takes you
offline so when I click offline look at
this
well I click Thursday it doesn't work
anymore
right click Friday it doesn't work
anymore things broken so I have to show
you this because we're gonna fix this
here in just a second if i refresh the
page what's gonna happen what the
Internet's not available
I get the dinosaur game how many of you
are aware that this is a game right so I
have a 13 year old boy who has an Xbox
he has a Playstation he has a laptop he
has all of these things because he's
Paul Ronny they're not his they're the
families but he's the only one that uses
them and I have caught him sitting with
his the Wi-Fi turned off on his laptop
playing the dinosaur game like really so
it's like flappy bird if you guys ever
played flappy bird before right so
that's I guess it's something to do when
you're bored okay so much of this talk
is going to be centered around how to
never see this screen again so we want
to get rid of this completely we're also
going to talk about chrome dev tools now
how many of you
well one hopefully you use chrome dev
tools because if you don't you're
missing out on quite a bit of power
there is also a lot of tabs to the right
side of network very rarely historically
have people ventured you look at the
console you can look at
elements you kind of maybe go to network
very rarely do people like venture past
that because then it gets weird but
we're gonna spend a lot of time past
that all right so we said of the problem
now let's actually talk progressive web
apps there is a tool or there used to be
a tool called lighthouse and what
lighthouse did is it would look at your
application it would analyze your
application tell you all the things you
needed to do in order to make a
progressive web app well lighthouse
became integrated into chrome dev tools
and the only reason I tell you that
little anecdote very shortly is because
when I go to chrome when I go to this
audits tab over here there is a
lighthouse icon the word lighthouse
never appears anywhere it's not it so
everybody's like what's the lighthouse
thing that's why because it used to be
called White House's integrated in what
audits does if you haven't used this
before you should you should use it for
a lot of different reasons it will
analyze your website for performance
best practices accessibility SEO type
things it's it does all this work for
you and what we're gonna do I'm gonna
take it back online first because if I
don't nothing will work all right I'm
back we're gonna go to audit I'm gonna
do a performance because fast was one of
the things we're gonna do a progressive
web app on it and then I'm gonna run my
audit well what's the first thing it did
I made it into a phone right so it
shrinks it down and make sure everything
still lines up and it's gonna run
through this audit process and it's
gonna say hey performance is OK at 78
that's not fantastic progressive web app
42 that is that's not a progressive web
app I mean ultimately too so I want to
talk about one thing first remember the
one of the first things I'm gonna flip
back over for literally one slide the
one of the first things we need
to do for a progressive web app is make
it fast we want it to be snappy because
if you're on a slow connection or your
honor no connect if nothing happens if
you just sit and spin people tune out
and they go away if you can get
something to paint quickly people will
stay engaged so it's better to paint
something and then do nothing for a
little while while you're gathering than
it is to stay white until everything's
ready and then pop up so we want we want
the first paint to be really good
luckily for us in chrome dev tools we
have this cool performance tool that
will actually say actually most of this
the first paint is 1.8 seconds speed
index to most of it's pretty good we're
8.4 seconds to interactive that's pretty
horrendous actually and it also gives
this cool little trace to let you know
exactly what happens when your website
loads and this is actually worth a
little bit of time we're not gonna spend
the but next time you go back to work
Monday and analyze your website go to
this and just see what's happening
because what you could actually see down
here at the bottom is notice for the
first hundred milliseconds I've got a
white screen and then as things start to
load now I have a blank screen I've got
no text but at least I've got some
colors and then I can kind of move
across look at that now I've got my
agenda I still have no data and then as
things load down here and as things
render I start to get and you'll
actually see right here my Thursday and
Friday are squished together I'll see my
CSS load my CSS be parsed and applied
and now they split apart because that's
my CSS is dealing with the placement of
all my words right so I can walk through
down here and see everything that's
happening now the biggest problem
for this website is time to interactive
is horrible first problem is I'm running
local right and when I'm running local
against development
I have not minified anything and so it
watch this
so in create react app I can actually do
npm run build then what npm run build is
going to do is it's gonna it's got a
package everything up it's going to
minify at all its gonna keep it all
condensed it's gonna be awesome once
that gets done i can actually serve this
page and it serves it to a different
port which is super helpful because i
don't have to kill my other one same
thing but notice much faster when I go
to audit I'm just gonna do the
performance out of here when I go to
audit 98 so just the one minification
piece is all it took to make so if
you're not minifying your bundles like
that should be compelling to you it
minify your bundle all of a sudden
everything works it works super great
this the other cool thing about this is
it also tells you look at this
opportunities eliminate render blocking
resources I have a full half second
where my render isn't happening because
of these things so 900 milliseconds to
load bootstrap MnDOT CS well I'm not
gonna not load bootstrap but you get the
idea
sometimes if these are non critical CSS
you can stick them down at the bottom
instead of at the top and they'll render
later or you can delay rendering all
kinds of things like that
okay so I just want to take a minute and
show you guys that let's go back to 3000
let's run this one more time and not do
performance just progressive or about
and then let's look at what we get back
all right there we go 42%
a whole bunch of stuff is broken let's
talk about that all right so the first
thing we're gonna address is the big
thing that we're gonna address which is
does not respond with the 201 offline
which on its face if you're just walking
in new sounds absurd right we're offline
I want you to respond with a 200 okay
and the way you do that is because you
have this thing down here called does
not register a serviceworker
so let's talk about service workers this
is the meat of a progressive web album
so I'll show you a whole bunch of stuff
we'll get through
who knows what a web worker is all right
I've got a couple
I won't call on you don't worry so so a
web worker is basically this thing this
piece of JavaScript you can stand over
to the side and let it process things
separately on a separate thread than
your main JavaScript thread because
remember javascript is single threaded
you only have one thread to do work so
if you if you have other things you can
do that you don't want to tie that
thread up you can hand them off to a web
worker and let the web worker deal with
it okay a service worker is not it's
similar to a web worker the idea of a
service worker is a service worker is
kind of like a web worker in that it's
gonna sit to the side but it sits in
between your web browser and your remote
server and it manages all of the network
connectivity between the web browser and
the server and so for the purposes of
this conversation we're just going to
call it Jerry um how many of you were in
the keynote where Richard talked about
Jerry that's Jerry so for the purposes
of this conversation we're just gonna
call it so so basically what's gonna
happen for our application is I'm gonna
make that call to day zero yes and
Jerry's gonna sit over there and
I already have a copy of de 0j yes I
don't need to go to the network I can
just hand it back that's kind of awesome
and when Jerry first loads up Jerry's
gonna go and he's got pull the entire
website into cash and so that when the
browser says hey give me localhost 3000
Jerry's gonna say I have it all already
I don't need to go to the network I've
already got it I'm just gonna send it
back and so that's the purpose of a web
worker so or not a web worker service
worker do I have any security people in
the room okay this is normally where the
security people kind of freaked out a
little bit because think about what
you're doing you're injecting a piece of
code that's going to hijack all network
traffic between the browser and the
server there's a word for that right so
man-in-the-middle attacks and so one of
the requirements and you'll see this one
of the requirements of a progressive web
app is it must be served over HTTP
cannot serve it over HTTP because you
don't you can't you don't want these
things injected into your application
because the vast majority of users have
no idea this thing even exists
I'll show you why here in just a minute
okay so a service worker the the idea of
a service worker is embedded into the
browser itself so there's a couple
pieces of code you need to do in order
to make a service worker work the first
thing is you need to go to so navigator
is just a native JavaScript thing
there's nothing to react specific about
this that's vanilla JavaScript navigator
does Service Worker
dot register and that registers a
service worker it doesn't activate it it
doesn't install it it just registers it
and the browser's gonna say hey go give
me offline CAS and install it now a
service worker your service worker code
basically just responds to events and
that's all it does and there's four
events we're gonna talk about in this
talk so the first event basically so
like I said a service worker is just add
event listener
a bunch of event listeners we're gonna
add and when an event fires the browser
is gonna wake the service worker up and
say hey run your install event so what
we're gonna do on install
so when install happens we're gonna
precache the entire website so what
that's gonna look like is all of this
stuff that it takes to execute my
websites we're just gonna go out and
we're gonna pull it in and I'll show you
this here in just a second
and you'll actually see it happen in our
network window the second event that you
guys are gonna care about is fetch so
what fetch is gonna do is when when such
happens so when I do my Axios get that
fires a touch event and so the browser's
are gonna wake up the Service Worker is
a hey fetch event just happens and
what's gonna happen is gonna do is event
dot respond with from cache and it's
just gonna send back the cached thing
and so basically what this guy does
don't worry about the code so much I'm
gonna give you a little cheater guide
that's gonna do a lot of this stuff for
you so don't worry about it too much but
what this is gonna do is basically say
open this thing called caches which is a
serviceworker thing it's basically just
a local cache that the serviceworker has
access to and it's going to say hey if
this request is in my cache return it
otherwise I'm gonna throw an error which
is great all right so let's look at this
in practice so you guys could see it
work all right now I am gonna cheat I'm
just telling you now because the last
thing in the world you guys want to do
is sit and watch me write code so I'm
going to magically Julia Child is Julia
Child the thing in Portugal No okay
Julia Child was a famous cooking show
host and so a Julia Child would do it
she would do some stuff and then she'd
walk over to the oven and like cold the
finished one out of
the oven and set it down right that's
what I'm gonna do
I'm just gonna do a get next magically I
have a serviceworker okay
so let's talk a little bit about what
the serviceworker is in the context of
react and then we'll go so in my index
touch a yes index dot jsn react is the
the key it governs the whole thing and
it tells everything what to do you'll
notice I have this input star as service
worker from dot serviceworker excellent
that's the only line of code that
matters there let's look at Service
Worker okay if you have used create
react app before in the create react app
service worker there's gonna be a whole
bunch of code in here the first thing
you want to do is just delete it because
it's bogus you don't need that we're
gonna do our own because it's better
that way and I'm just gonna do there
somebody gate it remember that one line
of code and that's it you'll notice they
don't have scope on there because I
don't care about it for the context of
this demo but offline dot J yes and then
offline J yes is all is there's my
install event right there there's my
fetch event all the rest of this is
stuff you've already seen okay let's go
look at this alright because it were it
already happens like I was showing you
this stuff and as soon as I did get next
it like happens so let's look at what
just happened
notice all of this looks the same I went
I got a 200 index all that happened
because the last thing that happens is
offline Jes gets pulled it's actually
not even on this screen yet offline Jes
is the last thing that happened notice
as soon as offline JSP comes up you see
all this stuff with this little gear
icon what the little gear icon means is
this all the rest of this network
traffic local host index bundle
bootstrap man all of this stuff is all
being pulled by the serviceworker into
cache and you actually see that
happiness to know
by having this little asterisk thing
here now if I go and I click on Friday
notice I'm I'm still going to the
network which is weird
and so part of what we're gonna do is
we're gonna talk about some of the
oddness
that happens so the application tab we
talked about the audit tab let's look at
the application tab for just a second
so the application tab tells you a
couple of things you've got your
manifest which we haven't talked about
yet we'll get to that in just a minute
then we've got our service workers and
you'll see I have a service worker it's
up it's running it's active it's not
working but it will be don't worry I
like was expecting it to not work like
this isn't where the demo breaks that
comes later
and then down here one other thing
that's cool on this application tab is
look at all this stuff that I have all
my storage my session storage my cookies
all of that stuff is accessible here so
this tab isn't just about about
progressive web apps and service workers
this tab gives you all the information
about your whole site but what you'll
see down here is my cash only cash only
was the name of our cache so in our code
notice I called the cache cache only
because that's what we're doing right
now we're only serving from cache and so
you can see all the stuff that was
cached know what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna come back over here I'm gonna
refresh okay now I'm actually serving
from cache you know I'm serving from
cache because a couple of things broke
and my icon broke up here because I
didn't cache that stuff but now if I
clear and I clicked Friday notice if
you're in the back you may not see this
but over here on size I have from
serviceworker so my day one that got
pulled is coming from my serviceworker
now it didn't come from the network
there was no network
traffic happening now as I click these
two things and I I know that because if
I click offline remember when I clicked
offline before and everything broke and
you're like well that's obvious well I
had to do that to prove to you that now
this is working now I can still go back
and forth between Thursday and Friday
despite when I'm offline what's gonna
happen when I hit refresh the whole
thing still works so now I have a fully
functional website that's working even
when I'm offline which is way more
impressive than you all are giving me
the impression that it is but that's
okay
I did set it up quite a bit we talked
about it for a while before we got there
if I had just shown it right off the bat
you probably be more impressed but
that's cool there's a fundamental flaw
with this that you may have already
picked up on because I am only serving
from cache so that's going to cause a
problem here in just a second because
what happens when if I go to de 0 dot
JSON and Richards sick Richards not
coming in today so I'm gonna beat this
joke to death and come and say Jerry is
gonna speak in Richards place what's
gonna happen when I click I'm gonna save
this I'm gonna flip over and I cook
Friday I'm gonna click Thursday I still
see Richard Campbell because I'm offline
I'm gonna go back online i'm gonna click
friday I'm gonna click Thursday I still
see Richard Campbell why don't I see
Jerry
I'm still serving it from cash so
realistically that's not really what I
want to do right in theory it makes
sense let's just cash everything and
just serve from cash but when things
change that doesn't work so we're gonna
add one more piece to this it's gonna
deal with a lot of that stuff for us so
what we're gonna do is I'm gonna come
back here I'm gonna undo this oh wait
before I do that hold on I wanna show
you one more thing because this there's
one more a little freaky think what
happens if I have a bug in my
serviceworker
everything breaks it's okay because
what's gonna happen I'll come back over
to applicate to application and we'll
look at service workers I'm gonna pull
this up I'm gonna change my service
worker so let's go to my service worker
my offline yeah yes and let's change
this to NDC so now I've changed my
service worker what's going to happen so
what's gonna happen is the website's
going to load and then it's gonna check
to see if offline j/s is available and
if it's different it's got to do a byte
compare and if it's different it's gonna
load it if it's not different it won't
so let me save this flip back over here
refresh my page
ah I have my old Service Worker is still
activated and running you'll see my new
Service Worker is waiting to activate it
went through a process it happened fast
so you probably didn't see it but it
said installing the new one waiting to
activate now because we installed it
you'll see down here at the bottom I now
have an NDC cache because on install I
go and cache everything another event
that fires that we're not using but we
could use is on active activate we could
do the pre cache on activate and not
cache yet but
this is gonna sit here in waiting to
activate until everything that has been
served by the previous service worker is
no longer active
so that's painful and I don't want to
close the browser and do all of that
stuff so I'm just gonna click skip
waiting there we go and now it's working
and now everything's served from Jerry
okay
so let's change this a little bit so now
I've got to me undo this discard changes
undo that one discard changes excellent
get next okay
now this one's called network first so
let me show you what the difference is
and then I'll show you what's happening
if I go to offline Jes still says cache
only because I didn't change it but look
at what fetch does what fetch does now
is I go to the network so from network
and then I do a catch so I'm gonna try
the network and if that fails then I'm
going to go pull it from cache that
sounds more realistic like what we want
to do right so the way that works is
let's come back over here to the browser
its refresh notice I'll skip waiting all
right so now if I come over to network
and I scroll this down and I clear my
network out if I click Friday Thursday
Friday notice it still says from
serviceworker but it also goes and pulls
it so like day one has two entries now
so it pulled they won from the
serviceworker but notice the little gear
icon says that the serviceworker also
went and pulled day one from the network
so that means when I click on Thursday I
see Richard Campbell
when I'm offline it still works
notice it's failing I get the Reds and
then serve but if I come over to my
browser and I go to day zero and I
change Richard to Jerry again
and I clicked Thursday it still says
Richard why because I'm still offline if
I go back online
now it says Jerry ok that's a lot
there's a lot of words there a lot of
code so we're gonna cheat because that's
what a good developer does right you
have two options right the first option
is you go to stack overflow then you say
help me write a serviceworker which is a
bad idea who uses Stack Overflow if you
don't raise your hand you're lying
so the general rule attack overflow is
everybody aware of this the check marked
answer is never the right answer it's
always the one right below it and it
doesn't matter right it doesn't matter
where in the world I am whether I'm in
America Europe Africa wherever everybody
laughs at that joke because we all fight
the same battles right and that battle
is I wish we could vote for the check
mark but we can't and that's a flaw in
Stack Overflow
so here the other way we're gonna cheat
is there is a website called service
work dot RS if you walk away with
nothing from this talk which is highly
likely walk away with this this website
gives you everything you need to build
service workers and let me tell you a
little bit now this is Mozilla so they
know something about the web a little
bit and look at all this stuff they have
so Hey look Network our cash cash only
cash an update cache update and refresh
if you want to cash in update look
here's your index J yes
here's your server and here's your
serviceworker this is the code for your
serviceworker with explanations on why
to build out your whole serviceworker
and these things get complicated
so catch update and refresh remember
what was the number one most important
thing fast
you wait it's gonna not the number the
first thing I mentioned how about that
the first it has to be fast so what if
when I click on Thursday I serve the
cache thing back then I go to the
network I pull the new data from the
network and then I update the screen
that's a little bit more compelling
right there's your code that does that
so that's how that'll work so this is
important and you want to understand
this part of it ok that's serviceworkers
which is the the core the meat of a
progressive web app but that covers the
work offline part there's another piece
to this I didn't run my take my word for
it because I'm not gonna go run the I'm
not gonna make you sit through another
audit does not read your register
manifest user will not be prompted to
install the web app so when you go to
the web site I want you to get a little
pop-up that says install to my desktop
that's kind of cool I don't have to go
to the web store anymore I could just
click a button and have it look all
right so let's talk about the manifest
file ok here's another thing that's
interesting so who knows what a manifest
is not in this contract just in the word
context okay what's the Portuguese word
for manifest manifest manifest oh ok
which is also kind of funny because
again no matter where I am in the world
it's basically just manifest so we all I
speak a little tiny speck of Portuguese
I know that word manifesto ok so that
was easy
ok Soho and agua is that right or do I
have a horrible American Act
agua is that right it's decent
it's decent okay that's fair I
appreciate that you're being nice okay
so it's also a very simple word so all
right manifest so what is a manifest
think about it not in context of this
but in context of like shipping right so
you're a coastal city what is a manifest
file
somebody tell me or a man I manifest it
kind of it describes like a shipment it
gives you everything that's in the ship
man and the details around the ship man
it's just kind of the to address and all
of that kind of stuff this is the same
thing all a manifest file is it's a JSON
file that describes the webpage as if it
were an application the important things
like what's the icon
what's the start URL what are the main
colors of the thing that kind of stuff
gets deposited into this thing called a
manifest file and we just link it just
like a stylesheet or something we just
pull in a manifest just like this and
it's gonna look like this so the name of
our app is event schedule we have a
theme color we have a display type a
scope because it could just you know it
could be a sub part of your application
right it doesn't have to be the whole
thing and then a list of icons and what
this is going to do is it's going to
give you access to your or install your
application so okay back over here let's
do our next manifest okay so first
things first right here I have a link to
a manifest file that's all it is and
then I have a manifest file it's not
complicated it's not even hard that's
all there is to it
but what that's going to do
it's when I come back over to my webpage
and I go to my application and I go to
manifest it's going to be empty because
updating the manifest didn't force my
browser to refresh so I'm gonna refresh
now I have a manifest file and it's all
these same things right so I've got my
name I've got my event I've got my icons
all that stuff and I have this little
button right here called Add to Home
screen just to prove something I'm gonna
come here apps notice I've got postman
I've got a couple other things but I
don't have my event schedule so I'm
going to go to event I'm gonna click Add
to Home screen and I get this little
pop-up add this site to your shelf to
use it at any time I'm going to click
Add I'm gonna click create and now in my
little shelf I have a vent schedule so
it has installed it as an app now that's
not really very cool actually but what
potentially is cool is this because I
bear with me take out your phone and go
to this address bitly NDC Porto because
the only way I can properly express to
you some of the things about this is to
have everybody experience what's
happening here so when you go to this
website it's just exactly the same thing
we've been looking at so now on your
phone you have a progressive web app
that has the schedule for the rest of
the day you're welcome so but but how
many of you got a install to your home
page alright so those of you who did not
notice there are people with their hands
up and I will tell you one thing about
the people with their
and one thing about the people with the
hands down people with the hands up are
most likely Android users right the
people with their hands down our Apple
users know what do you have interesting
Firefox on Android okay right so if
you're an Apple user do me a favor go to
share save to home screen which is not
an intuitive place to put the share
button or the add to home page button
why would you put it under so that
should work for you and then you can
play around with this a little bit you
can turn off mobile data you'll see that
the thing still works you can launch it
from your desktop all of that stuff
works whoo-hoo from the Apple got the
share add to homepage did that work yes
okay
not impressed at all are you but that's
okay okay so so just to give you a
little bit so the reason why I do that
for the whole room is you kind of see
where the state of progressive web apps
are right he is Firefox doesn't work
right Android Chrome users which you
know are the good people it works it was
fine the Apple users had to go through
an extra hoop in order to get it to work
and some of you probably just won't get
it to work at all on your phone
Microsoft especially if you're on a
Microsoft device it will not work not
because Microsoft devices are bad but
because they actively have refused to
implement that feature why let's think
about this for just a second why would a
poland' Microsoft be reluctant to allow
you to intuitively install an app from
the browser money you're circumventing
the app store therefore they're not
getting their revenue that's exactly
right what you are starting to see
google has already done this is the Play
Store will actually allow
you to serve progressive web apps
through the App Store an apple will not
be far behind so pretty soon you just
have to build your progressive web app
and you can serve that through the App
Store but if you're gonna serve it
through the App Store why not just write
an app so that's a whole different
conversation but okay yep
so we've installed we've served offline
we've got our Manifest thing working I'm
going to demo for you this is a little
bit more complicated there's a lot more
to it and we only have like ten minutes
so I'm gonna demo for you push
notifications I'm not gonna like walk
through it as deeply as I have because
you can go out to that service worker
page but I want you just to see it work
and what the pieces are so I'm gonna
kill this boom and I'm gonna okay so
okay sorry I have a back-end and I'll
talk to you about the backend here in
just a second but let's look at the
front-end in this front-end if I go to
my offline J yes this is different I'm
not caching at all on this one I have
another event two other events that I
want to talk to you about the further it
navigated away but while I'm here let's
let's clean this up a little bit because
notice there we go I still had the cache
one and so that wouldn't none of it
would work and boom okay so let's go
back over here now I have another event
called push and what that push event is
gonna do is it's going to serve up the
push notification so so when a push
notification happens the browser is
going to wake up the service
whereas they fire the push notification
and it's gonna fire that the next one is
notification click so what notification
click does so you click on a
notification we're going to launch our
website just remember that again all
this codes going to be available over on
the Service Worker thing so don't worry
about the code as much as like the okay
the other thing I want to show you is
this
remember Service Worker jes was like
just this one line of code before well
all of them meet of a push notification
is done outside of your Service Worker
you've got to register all this stuff
and so just very quick
I have push management get subscription
what push manager get subscription is
going to do you've seen this before
localhost 3,000 would like to you to
enable push notifications click OK or no
to enable put how many of you have seen
that at least one time on the Internet
how many of you click yes by default
probably none of you right because it's
annoying and we don't want to do that
but in this case we do because if a if
the schedule changes and you're gonna go
to you know room for you got a push
notification that says hey the schedule
is different you don't wanna go that
session anymore you want to know about
that the way push notifications work is
there's all kinds of security around
them so there's a thing called a public
key you've got to go out to the server
you've got a pull of public key you get
the key your exchange keys and then you
subscribe so when you load this webpage
this little piece of code is gonna
happen that's gonna call that's gonna be
subscribe and then I'm gonna actually
post to register and what that posts or
register is gonna do is send the
subscription and I'll show you what a
subscription looks like because all this
endpoint does and actually you you'll
see it back behind it all that endpoint
on my back-end is just do a consult log
so that's it you'll notice and I will
this code will be on is on github so you
can just go pull it I'm gonna walk you
through the little pieces of it okay
send notification or register notice
when they call register I just print it
out so let's look at this and post me
that is very small I will make that
bigger hold on okay all I push
notification subscription is is an
endpoint notice Google API comm / f cm /
then / a whole bunch of stuff that I'm
because it's unique like its global
unique it's got to be a big long weird
string then I have some keys I've got my
public key that vapid key that so I have
to have that and then I have a message
and that message says Jerry is filling
in for Richard and so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna click send and everything's
gonna break because it always does
hold on don't freak out it'll be fine
because the first thing I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna clear my storage we didn't
talk about this the last thing on the
application tab is clear storage all of
this stuff my service workers my cache
all of that stuff I'm gonna clear out
and get rid of so let's just clear that
out let's click refresh there we go I
got a new subscription with a different
end point you would never know it's a
different end point because you're not
going to read the big long thing I'm
going to click send and it said it did
it but it didn't that's less than
awesome
didn't show up over there that's showing
up off my screen these things are very
cool right up until the one time they
don't work okay
I'm going to do this one more time and
if it doesn't work you're just gonna
have to believe me that it works because
I don't have time to fix it
sorry okay
keynote everything's there if we go to
application I've got my serviceworker
it's there if I click offline notice
there's my push event all of that come
back here
copy my new subscription pace be sand
and of course none of that doesn't work
so anyway other than that any questions
from the crew other than why didn't that
last little demo work because I'll have
an answer for you in like three minutes
but you don't want to wait for that so
thoughts questions yes No so that's the
most important part of the whole thing
when I close my tab when I close my
browser that Service Worker is still
working and it's going to sit there and
it's gonna do it's going to wake up and
it's going to do everything which is the
important thing for the push
notifications that are not working but
yeah so so the idea is that's gonna work
no matter what so if I close the browser
and then that Service Worker sits there
no it doesn't do anything it's not going
to do anything until something happens
that makes the browser wake up and
execute my Service Worker but until that
happens it's it'll it's active but it's
not consuming any resources if that
makes sense
other questions yep
yep
so no it it fetches them again from the
network and so what what you see and we
looked at this a little earlier so
you'll see all of the assets come down
and the last thing that comes down is
offline j/s and then when as soon as
offline j/s comes down it goes and pulls
everything again because until that
service worker is installed it's not
managing anything and so it has no
awareness of anything else that's gone
on around it until it's installed then
it will go well yes but it also happens
completely in the background so so it's
not that traffic doesn't impact the
users experience in the browser at all
because it's it's operating in a
separate thread over in the service
worker thread but yes I mean don't I'll
put it this way if your amazon.com don't
create a service worker that caches
every request that people make and like
then you have all of Amazon cached in
the browser like don't do that that's
that's not gonna work for you okay
excellent
any other questions
okay so in Internet Explorer 9 or
something older the serviceworker
doesn't exist like so if I come back
over to here and I go to that's the back
end if I go to my offline CAS what I
don't have that I should serviceworker
chaos is I should have that's my problem
but it's too late I figured it out but
it doesn't matter because I'm over time
and Rob speaking nuts okay because this
is still running and it's the other one
okay anyway sorry beside the point
notice here I say navigator dot
serviceworker register offline if
navigator
if serviceworker doesn't exist in
navigator i can't install the
serviceworker so what you would do is
you'd wrap this in an if statement if
you have to support ie9 you just say hey
if I have serviceworker do all the
serviceworker stuff if i don't don't
and then that page in ie9 continues to
function like normal it just doesn't
have any of the offline capabilities or
the push notifications or anything like
that if that makes sense
right which is why we use transpilers
even though I hate that phrase babble is
a compiler first of all it's not a
transpiler but yeah so yes make sure
that you're you're doing all that yep
okay that was my whole problem okay cuz
notice I hit command C it doesn't matter
okay alright any other questions thank
you guys very much for your time
hopefully you have a great rest of your
conference thanks for letting me hang
out
[Applause]